a lot of houses are burnt  they are  occupied the city russian soldiers are  all over the city  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  these are fakes  these are materials published by  ukrainian fighters in this conversation  this is just a part of the propaganda  [Music]  [Music]  it was like a scene from some  films when a woman says goodbye to a man  and then  she doesn't know if she ever gonna see  him again and that's what's happening to  my life that's so  that's something unbelievable i don't  know i don't know what's going to happen  to him  [Music]  even though that a lot of ukrainians  have been threatened and brainwashed and  of course some of them of course uh  consciously started following bandera  movement and other factions that were on  the side of hitler during the second  world war